[Music]
welcome to the most
extraordinary and unforgettable
experience available on this planet
tens of thousands of visitors a month
we've only just begun
nature's spectacle presented as
entertainment
i mean only a lunatic would build a
world-class resort on a ticking time
bomb of molten earth right
the mountain's waking up i need time to
study it we're all going to be fine
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is our only chance
we have to take
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate
i with that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way calm did
the same
[Music]
and godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
[Music]
and they're the last ones standing
for greatness
kong bows to no one
it's 20 years since the moon was hit
electricity for only an hour a day
barely any food and all you care about
is cosmopolitan
[Applause]
attention unregistered teleportation
his power is unbelievable beyond
anything i have seen
all we have is now i like you
i waited for this stepping in here makes
everyone nervous
fear not the game is more dangerous than
it may seem
all the hardships earth face are a
result of the war with cherno
we're about to go play football with
what's essentially a nuclear bomb
and everyone else thinks this is just a
game is that right
pretty much it yes
it's easier to risk your life when you
know you're supported by millions
even if they don't know the truth or
understand the risk
four young earthlings with incredible
powers
you show there is something to be
inspired by here we go
[Music]
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't
trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby what
really a con baby
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore
peace we must find the last dragon
i wish to join this fellowship of
chicory
let's go we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please let this
be it
we really need your help i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like
the best dragon have you ever done like
a group project but there's like that
one kid who didn't pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premier access
march 5th
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other while
we get rich
this is going to be fun
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal civilized
but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
let's
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
is exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between life
and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders never
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting
two versus what he's gotta be kidding
[Music]
smoking the aircraft
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Music]
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
and us
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and come but my plan was to
drive us away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
and me my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get a back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming do you often
dream things that happen
just as you dream them yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself now you
must learn to rule others
something none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you lose that
one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
so
[Music]
from your secret friends
[Music]
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
[Music]
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
[Applause]
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's going to be different goldie
what are we looking at
how are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world
is a video game i really want to kiss
you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
[Music]
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely
right who is he or she indeed
this loser is ruining the game man i
don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader
terminate him
doing great guy in two days the game is
gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight together
i don't know what's happening right now
but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
they seem nice
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
go fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael murby got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing
what's up doc
[Music]
these are sharks but they can fly
you say
no flying fish stands between me and my
passengers
for disguise and the martial law it's
the only way that we can be saved
that's what i like to see
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands it
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it when i do just
imagine the lives that could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked the legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
good night
[Music]
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
call it lock
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
[Music]
you